premier sujet donc cette proposition par
emmanuel macron de nommé commissaire
européen
thierry breton 64 ans patron depuis dix
ans du géant numérique
atos l'idée ne semble pas incongru
compte tenu de son expérience dans le
privé dans le public et dans la sphère
politique il était ministre des finances
de mini de l'économie pardon souvenez
vous mais il ya un hic dans son gros
portefeuilles figureraient outre la
politique industrielle la défense laisse
passer le marché intérieur le numérique
or la société qu'il dirige en ce moment
atos est un géant du numérique qui
touchent des subventions publiques
européennes
d'où quelques réactions agacées voir
outre aider ce matin dans la classe
politique comme par exemple celles de
l'eurodéputé europe ecologie les verts
yannick jadot sur rmc donc on va avoir
un souci de conflit d'intérêts et y
compris j'ai cru comprendre que thierry
breton était encore actionnaire de son
entreprise donc qui va piloter le
numérique les subventions publiques
notamment qui vont à son entreprise dont
il est actionnaire
donc ça risque probablement d'amener à
une redécoupage de ce genre de un
portefeuille commissaire européen va
réduire la capacité de ce commissaire à
agir sur le numérique est essentielle
sur la politique industrielle on a un
goût et joint extraordinaire gala ziari
vous êtes aussi choquées ou gênées par
cette heure je pense que yannick jadot
et de mauvaise foi ici parce que dans un
monde où le politique interfère avec la
quasi totalité de votre existence l'état
taxe subventionne réglemente une
multitude de secteurs il n'y a pas un
seul citoyen qui peut se targuer d'être
dans une position de neutralité
vis-à-vis du politique et de la
puissance publique
donc j'ai envie de dire moi que ces
conflits d'intérêts nous sommes tous ce
sujet ces conflits d'intérêts la seule
manière de supprimer les conflits
d'intérêts c'est de supprimer la
politique en tout cas de réduire le
champ d'intervention de
de la politique alors moi en tant que
libéral ça ne me dérangerait pas du tout
mais j'ai cru comprendre que beaucoup
n'étaient pas de cet avis là donc je
pense que ceux qui aujourd'hui glorifie
la place du politique dans le monde et
bien doivent aussi jouer avec ses
contradictions et avec les conséquence
logique d'une telle situation
maintenant sur les qualités de monsieur
breton moi ce personnage je n'ai
absolument rien contre lui il est plutôt
respectée dans nuit des affaires il a un
bon bilan dans le secteur privé on l'a
rappelé là où je suis un peu attristé
j'ai envie dire c'est que ces
compétences qui aurait pu être plus
utile celle restée dans secteur privé
est bien vont être détournés puisque
celui ci va être happé à bruxelles pour
exécuter des tâches en réalité à mon
avis très improductive
on en a parlé de la du portefeuille de
la politique industrielle c'est quoi la
politique industrielle c'est tout
simplement la faculté à donner à une
classe de fonctionnaires de dilapider
l'argent des contribuables dans des
projets à l'utilité incertaine dans la
mesure où ces fonctionnaires n'ont pas
toutes les incitations à se montrer
diligent avec un agent qui ne leur
appartient pas donc les gabegies sont
sont quelque chose qui sont très
courants dans la politique industrielle
je pense que monsieur breton oui je
pense qu'aujourd'hui l'europe a besoin
d'attirer des investissements des
capitaux privés doit se doter d'un
environnement du neuf dans un
environnement institutionnel fiscal
attractif pour attirer les investisseurs
mais pensez que c'est avec une politique
en dessous c'est donc en donnant à des
fonctionnaires la responsabilité
d'investir l'économie qu'on attend à des
résultats satisfaisants me semble être
une douce illusion et je pense que
monsieur breton aurait été beaucoup plus
utile à son pays s'il était resté au
secteur privé puisqu'il n'y a rien de
productif qui pour accomplir mon avis à
bruxelles on a posé la question aux
internautes la désignation de thierry
breton pour la commission européenne
entraîne-t-elle un conflit d'intérêts
est quand même 65 % donc les deux tiers
répondu oui richard wehrli vous êtes
aussi sur cette ligne là il ya quand
même un petit problème selon vous il y à
une question et il y à une audition qui
va avoir lieu
et donc la réponse elle va se trouver
lors de cette audition on peut penser
que les parlementaires européens
d'autant qu'il ya eu l'épisode précédent
de sylvie goulard qui a été retoquée
elle pour des considérations éthiques
au vu des problèmes judiciaires qu'elle
avait eu en france je pense que les
députés européens à commencer par les
amis de monsieur jadot vont préparer
leurs questions de manière extrêmement
ciselé donc on va voir première
donnons à monsieur breton l'occasion de
répondre entendons ce qu'il va dire
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'il est
encore actionnaire de sa société s'ils
annoncent qu'ils se séparent de
l'intégralité de ses actions
il faudra l'entendre dont celui qui
vient là aussi pour réguler ouest au
numéro sur ce sujet si vous voulez je
pense trois choses la première chose
c'est que à voir un dirigeant
d'entreprise qui par ailleurs a quand
même été également ministre de
l'économie et des finances dont il
connaît les rouages bruxellois dit du
côté d'un état mans c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
monsieur breton est à un âge où il a
fait sa carrière met cette compétence
industrielle de chefs d'entreprise au
service de la commission européenne très
franchement ça me semble pas idiot du
tout la deuxième chose c'est ce qu'on
vient de dire il y aura une audition
respectons là et les communes les
députés européens avant sûrement faire
feu de tout bois
ils ont en plus des comptes à régler
avec emmanuel macron ne l'oublions pas
ils l'ont montré
et enfin troisième chose dans son
portefeuille là oui il y a un problème
et le problème n'est pas monsieur breton
à mon avis le problème c'est le
portefeuille on lui a donné beaucoup
trop de choses à se portera groupe et
c'est ce que la france a dévolu
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être ce qui l'a
largement nuit à sylvie goulard on a mis
le marché intérieur on a mis le
numérique on a mis la défense on a émis
la culture et la télévision
donc là on peut se poser une vraie
question il serait pas idiot que madame
vendeurs liliane la présidente de la
commission se penche sur le dossier
et peut-être propose un portefeuille un
peu différent à monsieur breton qui à
mon avis a une vraie compétence sur le
marché intérieur par exemple et dans ce
cas les possibilités de conflits
d'intérêts seraient nettement réduit
fodé gaby 6,7 cette mini affaire prend
un peu d'ampleur est ce que ça va encore
un peu plus séparer le l'opinion qu'a le
grand public sur les élites quiros mono
s'arrange entre elles parce qu'il ya un
risque
est-ce que c'était ça d'ailleurs que tu
es sorti des enquêtes après la ferme où
l'art des enquêtes à la fin goulard ce
n'est pas grand chose dans le sens où
sylvie goulard et est très peu connu des
français c'est pas une personnalité qui
a particulièrement marqué alors que
thierry breton ça a été dit c'est un
homme politique il a commencé sa
carrière dans un cabinet ministériel un
sou monory dans les années 80 il a été
élu local emplois touchant ses ministres
qui a marqué dont j'ai regardé le
baromètre ifop fiducial pour match et
sud radio
on a vu qu'il y avait une popularité
forte 2005 2007 c'est une période de
croissance
à
ces fortes vous rappeler qu'à cette
époque dominique de villepin et jean
louis borloo se battait presse pour
annoncer chaque mois une baisse du
chômage assez fort donc ça n'aura pas le
même impact que sylvie goulard ça révèle
aussi de choses sur le maquereau nisme
d'une part cette volonté de débaucher
des personnalités issues de la droite on
est loin du en même temps on est loin de
l'adn originel du maquereau ni tout à
fait c'est quand une personnalité qui a
été marquée à droite et ministre lors du
deuxième mandat de jacques chirac
ça donne aussi à voir s'il ya une
deuxième affaire après affaire là à une
certaine fragilité du banc de touche ma
croyance et voilà l'avatar de ce nouveau
monde on est sur une logique d'experts
qui répond à une attente des français
mettons une sportive aux sports un
ministre un docteur au ministère de la
santé et ses tirs et botton koch
beaucoup de cases
est ce qu'il y aura conflit d'intérêts
comme l'a dit mon collègue très
justement est très sagement nous le
verrons mais en tout cas l'impact sur
est sans doute plus fort du côté des
français parce qu'il y aurait comment
dire une histoire qui dure est un récit
d'une sorte de récidive sa feuille
donnerait et puis il ya une image
nettement plus constituée auprès des
français de thierry breton comparé à
madame goulard bien sûr alors pour
certains cela dit cette question de
conflit d'intérêts ne se pose absolument
pas écoutés par exemple stanislas
guerrini délégué général en marche ce
matin sur france inter à propos de cette
idée de maquereaux la motivation
principale pour la nomination la
proposition par la france de la
nomination de thierry breton
c'est la compétence c'est que pour gérer
ce portefeuille qui est un portefeuille
extraordinairement vaste et complexe
il va s'agir quand même de la politique
industrielle de la défense du numérique
du spatial 7 vers tous les sujets sur
lesquels l'avenir de nos enfants
l'avenir de l'europe se joue
eh bien il fallut une personnalité qui
soit à la hauteur du portefeuille que la
france va occuper
je crois que si les bretons c'est cette
personnalité là alors il ya un autre
soutien qui est celui de françois bayrou
ce n'est pas très étonnant la
proposition de thierry breton at il
tweeté comme commissaire européen est un
choix remarquable sur des sujets majeurs
pour l'avenir de la france et de
l'europe une personnalité qui a une
expérience majeure et une grande
créativité
caroline valentin vous êtes aussi sur
cette idée que c'est quand même un homme
compétent et que tant qu'à faire autant
avoir des hommes compétents c'est
possible en fait soit ils sont
compétents il s'en profile d'intérêt
soit ils sont pas compétents et
effectivement il ne risque pas le
conflit d'intérêts ce sont des sujets va
ce sont des sujets techniques régénère
les suisses donc ça leur bête quel
portefeuille soulagement je suis
française je suis contente que le
portefeuille sonar ok bah oui parce que
le problème c'est que la commission
européenne ait quand même le dirigeant
de l'europe sont des gens qui ne sont
pas élus donc on est content quand ces
gens qui ne sont pas élus et qui sont
parfois en conflit avec les dirigeants
internes sont chez nous et ont des
bonnes relations avec nos dirigeants
politiques
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
dans la structure politique de l'union
européenne d'avoir quelqu'un qui est a
priori notre ami l'ami des dirigeants en
place qui est compétent sur ces sujets
là et qui a un poste très important
après sur les conflits d'intérêts
écouter victimes en six gardes c'est pas
chez atos ça va être un peu embêtant a
priori ne devrait pas les garder donc et
comme en plus ce conflit d'intérêts
potentiel a été détectée avant son
arrivée ses conséquences concrètes
devraient ne pas survenir
parce qu'il sait qu'il est sous
surveillance après il ya un deuxième
sujet un peu accessoire mais j'ai en
trade quand même parce que c'est un
sujet qui personnellement m'a grèce
c'est le sujet de la parité
donc on a troqué une femme sylvie
goulard contre un homme donc évidemment
le sujet de la parité hommes femmes ou
des hommes femmes je précise quand même
parce que vous savez si on s'amusait
faire de la parité
bah oui il faut faire la parité en tout
faire la parité hommes-femmes faut faire
la parité je jeune faut faire de la
parité noir blanc faut faire la part
étaient noirs maghrébins il faut faire
la parité maghrébins gland après on va
rajouter le sexe d orientation sexuelle
et où donc ce sujet d'apart été moi
personnellement je laborde parce que
parce que je crois qu'on a fait le tour
de thierry breton la donne donc voilà
donc on peut aborder prendre de la
parité et je pense qu'il est quand même
important de
souligner et à ceux en parlant de parité
que ce qui est important vraiment celle
individualités que l'individu et le ski
et son importance et ses compétences
personnelles c'est capacité personnelle
et non pas 10 ans ex et c'est pour
l'heure de police engagées quoi que ce
soit je pense pas qu'on ait encore fait
le tour de thierry bourdon fergani
dirige je me disais tout à l'heure cette
idée de gâchis en même temps il a une
triple casquette triple compétence il
était dans le privé il a commenté france
télécom atos il a doublé son chiffre
d'affaires et ses effectifs
il était dans la politique il n'a pas
été à son aise dhabi la rapée tout à
l'heure la faillite à la hauteur de sa
fonction il était dans le public
si on n'est pas des gens comme ça à de
telles fonctions qui mettons est ce qu
on ne se plaint pas trop justement de
c'est du gâchis je pas sûr que ça du
gâchis dont vous avez raison sur le fait
que moi je ne suis pas du tout comment
dire c'est pas le conflit d'intérêt qui
moi me me préoccupe puisque
effectivement on reproche souvent
l'administration d'être rempli de
carialis de mandarins qui n'ont jamais
mis un pied dans mon entreprise et qui
n'y connaissent rien et c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on garde la mentalité française
le culte de la fonction publique fait qu
effectivement beaucoup de bureaucrates
chargé de réglementer l'économie n'y
comprennent absolument rien
donc c'est heureux et qu'il ya une plus
grande circulation et d une plus grande
communication entre le public et le
privé et moi je ne suis pas du tout pour
une société si l'hôte et avec des gens
qui feraient que du privé et des gens
qui feraient que du public
c'est surtout le public qui me pose
problème mais encore une fois je je suis
sceptique sur cette tendance à accorder
énormément d'importance à la fonction de
commissaire européen la façon de mini
star est extrait colbertiste très
français qui pense que le salut de
l'économie d'une civilisation viendrait
de bureaux ministériels non le salut
d'une civilisation vient de la capacité
d'un pays à inciter des entrepreneurs à
entreprendre à commercer à investir et à
innover et cela demande
là encore un environnement réglementaire
fiscale souple compétitif et je ne crois
pas que monsieur breton sera chargé de
mettre en oeuvre ce programme là
puisqu'il a été désigné sur un programme
colbertiste en attend de lui
qu ils utiles qu'ils réaffirment qu'ils
le fassent émerger une europe plus
interventionniste c'est une vision très
franco française de l'europe
on attend parfois ça met des rats qui
leur sont dévolues et vert ici je suis
sceptique alors on verra mais je pense
que ce n'est pas ce qu'on attend de lui
et malheureusement c'est en ce sens que
je pense que sa nomination est un gâchis
que tu as dû rester au secteur privé
je partage mes jeux danse aussi parce
que c'est vrai que ce colbertisme cet
interventionnisme
c'est au coeur de cela il ya le rapport
des français aux politiques qui est très
différente des autres pays c'est la
capacité du politique a changé la chose
a changé la vie à transformer à peser
sur le cours des choses
et justement l'échelon européen est un
échelon paradoxal de ce point de vue là
est très différent du regard des
français
s'agissant du regard de du territoire
hexagonal
pour les français c'est une vraie
évolution depuis quelques années quand
même on est heureux sceptiques
on a conscience que sur des grands
sujets environnementaux économiques
migratoires les solutions maintenant
sont à l'échelle du territoire européen
dans toutes les enquêtes au moment des
élections européennes
envoyez que l'échelon européen en termes
des chenaux crédit il avait gagné et un
million de points par rapport à d le 14
mai il ya un jugement extrêmement sévère
sur toutes les instances européennes
quand bien même elles ne sont pas connus
quand elles ne seront pas connus sont
apparus et cotation de connu et pas
incarner on parlera sans doute de mario
draghi
le jugement est extrêmement sévère ce
qui crée une véritable tension
on a confiance qui vont peut-être plus
d'europe mais l'europe n'est pas le lieu
des solutions je suis beaucoup plus
sceptique sur ce que vous dites quand
vous dites que les choix européens c'est
l'échelon d'avenir ne suis pas certain
de ça on écrit c'est avec et je n'ai
d'avenir bien en compagnie avec avec un
journaliste suisse qui viennent un pays
très décentralisé 13 mike brant et et
tout ça montre que le localisme n'est
pas l'ennemie la procédure m'avait bien
ne considérait pas du tout antagonistes
mais c'est une vraie évolution par
rapport à juin 2009
alors à part que l'économie de la suisse
est tout sauf locale vous l'aurez
compris puisque au contraire si on a
fait le développement de la suisse et la
possibilité d'avoir de la mondialisation
et d'avoir des multinationales y les
établissements financiers les intérêts
et non ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
dit aussi quelque chose de l'attitude
d'emmanuel macro face à ce parlement
européen emmanuel macron a quand même
été giflé par le rejet de sylvie goulard
qui était vraiment une personnalité dans
lequel il avait investi sa confiance et
il pensait s'il l'a nommé qu'elle allait
passer la rampe
ça n'a pas été le cas il aurait pu il
avait une solution de repli cette
solution de repli que d'ailleurs les
députés européens lui susurrer à
l'oreille c'était michel barnier qui
était une bonne solution michel barnier
est un négociateur du brésil que tout le
monde respecte et il était d'un camp
politique de droite modérée tout à fait
acceptable pour macro et il avait été
précédemment responsable du marché
intérieur comme commissaire européen
macron a choisi une autre personnalité
une personnalité qui vient du monde de
l'entreprise
ça prouve aussi qu'il veut faire le
forcing qu'il a l'intention d'imprimer
sa marque plus que jamais sur cette
commission je trouve que c'est
intéressant
merci beaucoup